Life imitated art when Paul Hogan
fell for his "Crocodile Dundee"
love interest. There was just one
roadblock: his wife of 30 years.
Paul Hogan told the BBC that a trip to New York
inspired "Crocodile Dundee's"
fish-out-of-water tale, saying,
"I felt like an alien from another planet, some
of the 'Bushie' guys I know would feel even more
out of place. There's a myth that there is
a real Crocodile Dundee, but there isn't."
Still, many believe Rod Ansell's 1977 survival
story was the inspiration for the character Mick
Dundee. Ansell became famous in Australia
after surviving for seven weeks on limited
supplies in the wilderness after his boat was
capsized in the Northern Territory. Indigenous
Aborigines ultimately rescued Ansell, but when
people learned that he survived off the land,
and even resorted to drinking buffalo blood,
his unlikely survival story fascinated them.
Television host Michael Parkinson interviewed
Ansell, who told viewers he slept on the
floor at the luxury hotel in Sydney, just
like Mick Dundee later did in the movie.
In 1980, Ansell published his story in the
book, "To Fight the Wild," but Hogan never
admitted that Ansell was his inspiration.
After "Crocodile Dundee" became a hit,
Ansell grew bitter because he never
earned royalties from the film.
According to the Herald Sun, in 1999,
Ansel died after ambushing police in a
drug-fueled shootout that left one police
officer dead and other civilians injured.
The financing group that funded "Crocodile Dundee"
was the brainchild of Hogan's business partner
John Cornell, who envisioned an inventive model
to finance the independent comedy. They actually
chose to not partner with the Australian Film
Commission because they wanted full creative
control over the project. Instead, a Queensland
bank underwrote $7.1 million of the film's budget,
while Cornell found additional
funding from 1400 small investors,
including Michael Hutchence, the lead
singer of the Australian band INXS.
After they completed the film, Cornell flew to
the U.S. to look for a distributor. According
to The New York Times, Paramount snapped up
the U.S. distribution rights of "Crocodile
Dundee" when 20th Century Fox turned Cornell
down after watching only 20 minutes of the
movie. After the first and second "Crocodile
Dundee" movies were huge commercial hits,
Cornell told The New York Times that the
Fox executive had been extremely rude.
"I sometimes get pleasure from thinking about what
the look is like on his face at a time like this."
The first scene in "Crocodile Dundee" has
a big Easter egg referencing Paul Hogan's
life before acting. It happens when we see
the Sydney Harbour Bridge in the background
while Sue Charlton talks to her boyfriend
on the phone at the beginning of the film.
According to the Canberra Times, before
he got his break in showbiz on the talent
show "New Faces," Hogan worked as a
rigger on the iconic bridge. He told
IGN that he did the show on a dare and won
over the audience by roasting the judges.
"I went on 'New Faces' to take the mickey
out of it. I'm one of the few people that
ever went on a talent quest that had
no intention or desire to win it."
After appearing on "New Faces," Hogan was
interviewed at the Sydney Harbour Bridge
for the show "A Current Affair," which
brought him to the attention of future
business and creative partner John Cornell.
Cornell and Hogan started JP Productions,
and "The Paul Hogan Show" made Hogan famous
— first in Australia, and later in the U.S.
after the sketch series became syndicated
internationally. Hogan then became the face
of Australian tourism with an advertisement
inviting Americans to visit "the wonders down
under." This would later set the stage for
the success of "Crocodile Dundee" in America.
"Crocodile Dundee" was shot on location in
Australia and New York City. Production for
the "outback" scenes was filmed in the isolated
Kakadu National Park in the Northern Territory,
which had been home to a uranium mine.
Craig Bolles, the Australian location
scout for "Crocodile Dundee," selected the
isolated region because, as he explained,
"It showcased a part of Australia that I
don't think had been seen ... and it was
inherent in Paul's nature. He seemed
to fit into the landscape perfectly."
Although Kakadu National Park has since become
a popular tourist destination, Bolles explained,
"Kakadu was a very different place in
the 1980s to what it is today. Only the
main road was [paved] and there were no hotel
facilities at all as far as I can remember."
Because they were so far from
hotels, everyone on the cast and
crew slept in huts left behind by the
Pancontinental Mining Company. Despite
the dilapidated condition of the camp,
the cast and crew made the best of it,
spending their nights around a campfire
and creating a summer camp atmosphere.
After test screenings with American audiences,
Paramount trimmed seven minutes from the movie
to make an international cut. Barry London,
president of distribution at Paramount,
told the New York Times that they had to
quicken the pace to suit U.S. viewers.
Most of the cut screen time came from the first
half of the film where Mick Dundee is showing Sue
Charlton around the Australian Outback. During the
test screenings, American audiences also struggled
to understand the Australian slang in the film,
so much of that was cut as well. Additionally,
the f-word was dropped from the movie so
it could have a PG-13 rating in the U.S.
Paramount added quotation marks around
"Crocodile" on the posters and the title
card so everyone would understand it was a man's
nickname and not a movie about a crocodile.
Paul Hogan had planned on using a real crocodile
for close-ups during the scene where Sue was
attacked. This simply wasn't in the cards, so
production purchased a mechanical crocodile for
$45,000. Although the crocodile that attacks
Sue while she's cooling off in the water was
animatronic, there were real crocodiles
all over the set. They hired an armed
guard and a crocodile wrangler to protect
the production from croc interference. As
Hogan explained to Go Erie while promoting
"The Very Excellent Mr. Dundee" in 2021,
"We had guys up trees with rifles just in
case one came along and ruined everything."
Hogan told IGN that the water buffalo was the
real stubborn diva on set. During the interview,
he explained that the scene where he
mesmerizes the buffalo took all day, adding,
"Cause if the buffalo doesn't want to do anything,
it weighs 2000 pounds and you know, it doesn't."
Paul Hogan met his first wife Noelene Edwards
when they were teenagers at the swimming pool
where he was a lifeguard, and they married
young in 1958. Hogan told Australian Story,
"I had three sons by the time I was
22, so I had to grow up very fast."
Although Paul Hogan was still
married to Edwards while making
"Crocodile Dundee," he ultimately left
his first wife for his co-star Linda
Kozlowski. Hogan and Edwards had a very
public and ugly second divorce in 1989,
with Australian media outlets reportedly
depicting him as abandoning his family.
"I've got five children to think about,
and they were just as hurt as
I was, but in a different way."
Hogan married Kozlowski in 1990 in
Australia during a private ceremony
at a mansion he built as a wedding gift
to his bride. They had a son named Chase
and settled in Los Angeles, but eventually
divorced in 2014. Kozlowski told New Idea,
"Honestly, we just naturally
grew apart. [...] The divorce
was completely amicable [...] Everybody's happy."
"Crocodile Dundee" hit Australian
cinemas on April 24, 1986. Hogan
predicted it would be a commercial
success, telling Cinema Papers,
"I expect it to gross millions
of dollars around the world,
and I'm planning for it to be
Australia's first proper movie."
Hogan was right. Arriving in the U.S. in
September, "Crocodile Dundee" was one of the
highest-grossing films of 1986 and was only
beaten at the U.S. box office by "Top Gun."
It remains to this day the highest-grossing
Australian film at the Australian box office.
The film's success came with a downside:
unrealistic expectations. In
2022 Hogan told Mark Meets,
"Because of the ridiculous success of Dundee,
which is still the most successful independent
film ever made, it's sort of like, 'Oh,
whatever I do next will be a flop by
comparison. So why bother?' So mentally
I sort of retired after the first one."
U.S. audiences were already familiar with Paul
Hogan before "Crocodile Dundee" came out because
of the Australian tourism advertisements
he donated his time to during the '80s.
"You see, Australia is the world's biggest island,
and as you can appreciate, the accents
varies noticeably from one place to another."
When "Crocodile Dundee" became an
international success, it altered
tourism in Australia. In 2016, tourism
chief executive Tony Mayell told Perth Now,
"The film helped put Australia on the map."
According to The Guardian, they even started
giving "Crocodile Dundee" tours in Kakadu
National Park, where the movie was filmed, and in
Darwin, where you can have close encounters with
live crocodiles. Three hours away in Jabiru,
you can stay in the indigenous-owned Kakadu
Crocodile Hotel, which is shaped like a
crocodile. From there, you can explore
the wilderness of Kakadu through guided tours,
scenic flights, or arts and crafts lessons with
indigenous Aboriginal tribes who have lived in
the Northern Territory for at least 40,000 years.
The film's sequel, "Crocodile Dundee II,"
was a top five box office hit in 1988,
but after that, the franchise
seemed dead. Then in 2001,
"Crocodile Dundee in Los Angeles" came out
and proved without a doubt that it was.
Nominated in 2002 for the Razzie for worst sequel
or remake and sitting at 11% on Rotten Tomatoes,
"Crocodile Dundee in Los Angeles"
was a box office disappointment and a
critical disaster. The film's production was
troubled as well. According to Den of Geek,
there was a dispute over the script between
screenwriting duo Matthew Berry and Eric Abrams
and Hogan. Hogan extensively rewrote their
screenplay and believed he should receive
the writing credit. Ultimately, the Writers Guild
sided with the original scriptwriters. They gave
Berry and Abrams credit despite Hogan appealing
the decision. Hogan told The Los Angeles Times,
"Anyone who ever saw the first two movies will
know who wrote whatever comes out of anyone's
mouth, but because I didn't change the plot and I
am the producer, I was not credited as a writer."
In January 2018, teasers began dropping
on the internet for what seemed to be
a "Crocodile Dundee" reboot starring Danny McBride
as Mick Dundee's son. It was followed
by a full trailer and a Super Bowl ad.
"When your dad did it, he was much…"
"Okay, well, my dad told me about this,
he was just like, yeah, I just came
up and was duh duh duh duh this."
But it was soon revealed to
be a 27 million dollar ad
campaign to revitalize Australian
tourism. McBride told Insider,
"It wasn't like I was looking to do
a Super Bowl commercial, but I just
thought the concept of this was just too funny
to see what people's reaction would be like."
Australia's Minister for Trade, Tourism, and
Investment, Steven Ciobo, told Tourism Australia,
"This is the single largest
investment Tourism Australia
has ever made in the US market and one
we believe will grow annual spend by
American visitors to $6 billion
[Australian] by the year 2020."
Fans hoping for an actual revival had their
hopes dashed, though, when Hogan told Today,
"It's not gonna happen."
In 2020, Paul Hogan starred in "The Very
Excellent Mr. Dundee," a satire where he
played a fictionalized version of himself.
The movie depicts him getting into hot water
on social media and meeting a bunch of other
old comedy stars. Hogan told Boomer Magazine,
"It's not a deep meaningful movie,
just a bit of fun. While it pokes fun
at Hollywood rules and how social media
through the modern online community can
give you a reputation that you don't
deserve, it's mostly aimed at me."
Hogan making himself the butt of the joke is
certainly familiar ground for the Aussie whose
self-deprecating humor won audiences back
in the '70s and '80s, though critics panned
"The Very Excellent Mr. Dundee," giving
it abysmal scores on Rotten Tomatoes.
In 2020 Hogan also released his memoir,
"The Tap-Dancing Knife Thrower: My Life
(without the boring bits)." Hogan told Go
Erie that it was the brainchild of his
longtime writing partner Dean Murphy.
"It was Dean again who talked me into doing
[the book], telling me that if I dictated it,
he'd write it down, so that
appealed to my lazy side."
Hogan might be done with Hollywood,
but that doesn't mean audiences have
forgotten him or that iconic
role from the land down under.